[Musik]
hass auf gar keinen fall
ich finde allein einen job ich brauche
deine hilfe nicht einstellen das regal
das regal können wir hinten auf die
ladefläche stellen
ok dann legen wir die matratzen nehmen
das regal
wohin sollen die kissen kann da was
kaputt gehen eigentlich nicht die gesten
können auch nach hinten
wir stellen sie einfach hinter das regal
auf den boden
ok dann legen wir die kleinen sachen an
die seite was machst du hier
ich will wissen warum nur so treffen
abgesagt hat ich habe das treffen nicht
abgesagt das war meine mutter deine
mutter ja natürlich wollte ich dich
treffen und da hat sie mich gefragt
worden nicht gehe
und da habe ich ihr gesagt dass ich im
deutschunterricht bin sie hat mich beim
linie aber wieso nico ich kann mir das
jetzt nicht erklären ich habe jede menge
ärger mit meinen eltern und darf sich
nicht mit fremden treffen aber ich bin
nicht fremd für meine eltern schauen sie
dürfen sich hier nicht sehen
nein mein vater